since the start of the war in Ukraine
back in February the U.S military has
added an additional 20 000 troops to the
European theater taking the total there
to around a hundred thousand and many of
those troops are in Eastern Europe only
on CBS mornings we're getting a look at
the U.S forces closest to the fighting
in Ukraine supporting NATO allies and
sending a very clear message to Russia
Charlie dagada is in Romania for us this
morning Charlie good morning
Good morning Tony Romania is now home to
the 101st Airborne Division it's the
first time it's been headquartered here
in Europe in nearly 80 years this is
some of the equipment they brought from
home a triple seven Howitzer ready to
roll at any minute
they're specifically trained to deploy
on any Battlefield in the world within
hours go go go go ready to fight
the reason one of America's most elite
aerosol divisions has been sent right
here right now
we joined Deputy Commander Brigadier
General John lubis and Colonel Edward
matatus commander of the second Brigade
combat team on board a Blackhawk
helicopter for an hour's Chopper ride to
the very edge of NATO territory around
three miles from the border with Ukraine
from the start of the war Russia
Advanced from Crimea along the Black Sea
to curse on aiming to capture port
cities like mikolai in Odessa to
landlock Ukraine we're right about here
why is it necessary to have the 101st
gear
we bring a unique capability for a light
infantry Force but again we bring that
Mobility through our aircraft and our
air assaults we skirt along the Black
Sea Coast as we head further north we're
roughly 20 miles away from Snake Island
as contentious Island that's been fought
over between the ukrainians and the
Russians currently under Ukrainian
control
at a forward operating site we watched
as U.S soldiers and Romanian troops
pounded Targets in a joint ground in air
assault
the tank rounds and artillery fire are
real
so is the enemy meant to recreate the
fight against Russian forces in Ukraine
a message to Russia and NATO allies
alike we're here the real meaning
for me to have the American troops here
is like if you were to have allies in
Normandy before any enemy was there
in all roughly 4 700 soldiers of the
101st Screaming Eagles from Fort
Campbell Kentucky have been deployed to
reinforce NATO's Eastern flank
you've had an opportunity to to watch
observe
possibly study
the Russians
what do you think of them so far so
we're uh we're closely watching them so
we're building uh objectives to practice
against that replicate exactly what's
going on in Ukraine we're the closest
American unit to be fighting in Ukraine
and what does that feel like what does
that mean it uh it keeps us on keeps us
on our toes right so
ready to fight tonight is a message that
we've heard repeatedly it's not just
about defending NATO territory but if
the fight escalates and NATO partners
are under threat they're fully prepared
to cross over into Ukrainian territory
if ordered to do so back to you in the
studio
oh boy Charlie daggered a force in
Romania 101st Airborne they've deployed
to every major conflict since D-Day and
you sure hope they don't have to add
another one of the list yes scary stuff
you're glad we have them though yeah
you're right about that